we all have goals in life some are
short-term some are long-term but what
is the motivation out of which we create
and pursue these goals the reason we
create goals in life is to create and
sustain a sense of motion without
feeling like we are moving towards
something we feel useless and uninspired
and experience and existential lethargy
we need goals to feel engaged and
connected to the natural world every
goal you set in life is ultimately a
goal of nature and evolution even the
most individualistic seeming of goals
are primed by some desire to benefit the
collective life around you you are part
of nature's progression and if you wish
to feel alive and a part of the system
of existence you must move forward with
it experiencing and participating in the
collective forward motion of life is
essential but we must also be careful to
not become so swept away by it that we
forget to also enjoy our individual
lives we must learn the balance between
actively working towards and pursuing
our goals while still being able to
enjoy our life around them our sense of
identity and self-worth do not have to
be attached exclusively to the cycle of
goal-oriented success the cycle being
goal task accomplishment repeat this
cycle infinitely regresses on itself and
searching for our overall well-being
within it only leaves us empty-handed
true well-being comes from enjoying and
being motivated towards goals while not
solely depending on them for a sense of
enjoyment and self-worth when your goals
become your only lifeline to life itself
you bring anxiety desperation risk
aversion and fear into them it is
important to be motivated and passionate
about the outcome of your goals but the
paradox is not being so overly dependent
on them that you forget to enjoy them
and take risks to develop them thank you
for watching if you found enjoyment and
value in this video please give it a
thumbs up share your thoughts in the
comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder